Hello everyone. Now I talk about the second basic laws of fluid mechanics, that is the linear momentum equation. Last time I was talking about conservation of the mass and Reynolds transport theorem and also the volume flow rate and mass flow rate, right? So linear momentum equation, so for the conservation of mass, it is very important
when we are calculating the velocity, right? Or whenever there is a force involved, you want to calculate some force, like drag force or lift force, then you have to apply conservation of mass, but also the linear momentum equation to calculate. So I will talk about a couple of examples of force calculation using control volume and also the linear momentum equation.
So the linear momentum equation will be the second equation of our flow governing equation. So I told you our flow governing equation is the Navier-Stokes equation. And then I told you there are five of them. Right? So number one is the mass equation. And then three vector equation in x, y, and z direction. That is the momentum equation.
momentum equation. We can have a linear momentum and angular momentum, but linear momentum is more widely used. I will introduce linear momentum first and then the energy equation. So I went over the mass equation. So now I go over the momentum equation. So B is the MV. So this time, what was the B? B is any property
where we can apply the Reynolds transport theorem. And then small beta is the dBdm, and that is the velocity. And again, we are assuming a fixed control volume. So this is a reminder of our Reynolds transport theorem, where the left-hand side is the Lagrangian perspective,
of the derivative. And then right-hand side is the Eulerian version of the flow derivative. So here, if we replace B by mV and beta by velocity V, then we have left-hand side, we have that, and right-hand side, that. And then based on the Newton's second law, so the linear momentum equation is based on the Newton's
second law, that is, F equals ma, right? So we have to, so this is, so we can consider as ma, and that has to be, say, equated by the summation of the force.
and then we will look into the x-direction, y-direction and z-direction. So sigma F is rho V. So this is a momentum flux. So here previously I said rho Va, what was it? That is the mass flow rate, right? Or Q is the volume flow rate and that was the Va, right?
And then rho v we associate as a mass flux here. Density multiplied by the velocity. So here rho v is the mass flux here. So sigma f is v rho dt and v rho vn. So we derive that from the Reynolds transport theorem.
and then what about the force? Force term should include all surface forces and also the volumetric body forces. Surface force meaning we have a pressure that is acting normal into the surface and then shear stress that is tangent to the surface and in a static flow, if it doesn't move and there is no velocity gradient,
every flow particle is moving at the same velocity, then we don't have any shear stress. So later on in some chapter, we will look into the shear stress in detail.
There is a very important concept that is related to the skin friction as well. So we will consider pressure for the surface force and then volume force.
will look into the gravity, gravity is always there, and buoyancy has to be considered when we are looking into the hydrodynamics, hydrodynamics meaning the water is involved, and if there is some immersed body, body immersed in the water, so let's simplify the momentum equation, so 1D momentum [Review note: Buoyancy is the resultant of surface pressure forces, not an additional independent body force when that pressure distribution has already been integrated.]
momentum flux at inlet and outlet. Momentum flux is the M dot V. So that is the momentum flux. M dot V, so from the previous, this is the control volume, and then this is the, we have to think about flux term coming in and out, right? So that is the MV dot, we are looking into the 1V.
So M dot V, why is M dot V? So there will be rho V and A, right? So we have V, V, rho A, so there will be M dot V, so this is velocity, velocity at in, in, out, sorry, out is positive direction, and then M dot V in, right?
that is the momentum flow. So this is the 1D momentum flux at inlets and outlets. Then steady and nondeforming, we impose the steady assumption, which means that this DDT term partial partial T term will go to zero. So this first term will cancel out. We have only those two terms left.
So, momentum flux out minus momentum flux in has to be the same as the summation of the force, and if we have the one inlet and one outlet, one represents the inlet and two represents the outlet, then the total mass flow rate, M dot, should be the same as mass flow in inlet and mass flow in outlet, right?
Okay, so sigma F is m dot times (V2 minus V1). So this V is the, for this time, this is one, sorry, it doesn't have to be one-dimensional. So I just put the vector notation here.
Then, a lot of times, we will look into a jet, like jet example, like water jet, or even the rocket, we have the jet exit, so pressure force is external, external pressure force on a close control volume, a control surface, their direction, its direction is always normal to the surface, and it's pointing outward or inward.
It is inward, right? So by definition, pressure is always pointing inward and surface normal vector is always pointing out, right? So this is a closed control surface and there is no external pressure. So we have the uniform pressure, then atmospheric pressure is the same everywhere.
so it could be taken outside of the integral, then the force. So this slide is looking into the force component by the pressure. So if the uniform pressure is everywhere, then Pa can be taken outside of the integral, then NdA will be summation of all that, and NdA, then there will be zeros, right?
because this is a closed surface or non-uniform pressure in the bead. So here PA atmospheric pressure is the same everywhere but then we have the some other pressure on top of the P. So P gauge is the P minus PA. So that is the amount of the pressure that should be felt by this closed surface.
So f is integral of the p minus pa, n minus n. If you take this inward as a positive, then it has to be minus n, we're also looking into it, right?
Then there is a p gauge. Sorry, not a page. There has to be p_gauge times minus n. And the integration of that should also be zeros as well. Right? Does this make sense?
because P gauge is the P minus PA, right? P gauge is the P minus PA. So if you integrate that along the DA, and you have the closed surface, so that will also be zero. Whenever you have a closed surface, and if it's not moving, right, it's fixed, then it will be zero, force will be zero because the acceleration is zero. [Review note: This zero-force claim is not generally valid for nonuniform gauge pressure. Only the spatially uniform atmospheric part cancels on a closed surface. A fixed CV can have nonzero net force balanced by momentum flux.]
And then for a nozzle section, so just an example based on the linear momentum equation, so we have a nozzle, this is the inlet and this is the outlet and this is the sidewall. For a nozzle section shown, find the net pressure if d1 equals 3. So we have, this is one state and this is state 2. And we have absolute pressure
of 40 pounds, 40 pound force here, 15 pound force everywhere, right? So if we look into the up and down, top and bottom, the pressure will be cancelled out. So we can translate that into a zero, zero pound force. And then left and right, if we, so this is 40 pound to the right, and this is 40 pound [Review note: The values 40 and 15 are pressures in psi, not forces in lbf. The resulting force on PDF page 22 is approximately 177 lbf.]
to the left. So you can just convert that into a zero pound force in the right-hand side, gauge force. So this is a gauge force and gauge pressure and this is the absolute pressures, right? So this is a P abs and this is a P gauge. Then there will be 40 minus 15 will be 25, right? 25.
Then our control volume will be selected outside of the nozzle plus the cut sections as a 1 and 2. So our control volume will be this one. That is our control volume.
then our force here is quite, it will be just a single, F will be P gauge minus N, the A will be, P gauge will be 40 minus 15, that is 25 already, and then P gauge unit will be pound force divided by the inch
and I, because this is a vector, it is one dimensional, and then the area will be, sorry, this is not the DA because I didn't put the I, so here will be 4 by 3 inch square, so there will be F will be
3, 1, 70, 7, I, pound, force. Okay, then we are looking into another force system.
When liquid flow passes through an elbow that changes the direction of the flow or water jet deflected by a vane into a different direction,
function. And it's important to determine what is the anchoring force required to hold the elbow and vane stationary. It doesn't move, right? So this is an example. So what I'm going to do, what I'm doing right now is how to utilize the conservation of mass and conservation of the linear momentum equation in a simple one-dimensional case to calculate the resultant force.
Okay, so this is a horizontal nozzle and then you have the flange bolt here. So since this is water and because the area changes, the velocity at the inlet will be different. So velocity at this location will be different from the velocity at the state tube, right?
So in this case, because of the velocity difference, it may move around. So we have the flange bolts here, and we calculate what is the horizontal force provided by the flange bolts.
So, at the one state, diameter is 12 inch, at the state 2, diameter is 6 inch, and then with inlet P1 is 38, pound-force per square inch, absolute, and P2 is, at the speed, is 56 feet per second, okay, and then water is at the
room temperature of the 20 Celsius. So here, since we have state 1 and state 2, our control volume should be like that. Okay, so that is our control volume. And sometimes you can consider as a force diagram. So you have to, like we do in a force-free body diagram,
We have to think about how much of the pressure is acting in state 1, and how much of the pressure is acting in pressure 2, and what is the velocity v1 moving to the right at the state 1, and what is the velocity of 2 at state 2.
two. And then what we want to calculate is the force acting, force exerted by the bolts to have the system stationary, fixed, right? So the flow number one is always select the control volume to make sure that includes the outside of the nozzle and then plus the cut sections in one and two, right?
So first apply the mass continuity equation, and here rho is the same, this is a one-dimensional and this is incompressible, rho is a constant, then what we do have M1 dot is the same as the M2 dot, right? And the rho is the same, so we have A1, B1, A1, B1 is the same as the A2, B2, right?
Then our V1, V1 and theta state 1, our diameter is 12 inch, so pi D squared divided by 4 is the A2, V2 is given, right? V2 is 56 feet per second. [Review note: PDF page 24 uses A1 V1=A2 V2 and A1=pi D1^2/4.]
So V2 is 56, and pi is square of 4, diameter there is 6 inch. So you have to be careful about the unit, but then this is feet per sec, this is inch, but that's okay, because we are looking into the left-hand side and right-hand side,
So as long as those units will be cancelled out, so from here our V1 will be 14 feet per sec.
Then let's apply the linear momentum equation. Remember sigma F, I haven't set the sigma, but then we know the M dot is the same.
Okay, so the momentum flux is M dot V2 minus V1. Okay, so this is a one-dimensional case, so I don't put the vector sign here. So f , okay, so what about the fourth term?
Fx will be, if we set that as a positive, F of bolts is a negative, minus F bolts plus, and then 23 pressure, right? So, 38 negative minus 12 is a 23, 38 minus 15 multiplied by the area. [Review note: The pressure difference used in the equation is 38-15=23 psi. The intervening number wording is not reliable enough to reconstruct as a precise quotation.]
Okay, so this area, right, so that will be, so we are looking into the resultant force here, right, so P1 is higher than P2, right, so 38 minus 15 is 23 multiplied by the area pi and 12 squared divided by 4, that will be 1.94
multiplied by the 4 over pi, 12 by 12 squared will be 15, right, so I'm guessing this one, right, m dot, rho A, V multiplied by the V2 minus V1 is 56 minus 14, that is F. [Review note: The spoken arithmetic is unclear. PDF page 24: -F_bolts+(23 psi)pi(12 in)^2/4=(1.94 slug/ft^3)pi(12/12 ft)^2/4*(14 ft/s)*(56-14 ft/s).]
of bolts is 1,700 pound force. So this is M dot, this is M dot, and these are the V2 minus V1 part. You know how to get rid of M dot? M dot is rho, U, A. Rho was, rho water was 1.94 slope per feet cubed, okay.
So, what's more important than the numbers themselves are, first you have to define a control volume, then apply the mass equation, momentum mass equation, and then apply the momentum equation, right?
and probably in your homework and the midterm, I will simply, you know, the one-dimensional problem is pretty easy, and also I will assume steady, so that you don't have to worry about the time variation, and also I will assume incompressible, incompressible, so those will be important.
And then a second example, so here this is not a one dimension, right? So we have the vane, and then this is a fixed, which means that if this vane is experiencing a water jet, some force by the water, you know, the direction changing water jet, then that has to be supported by the force F, right?
Okay, so a fixed vane turns a water jet of area A through an angle theta here without changing its velocity magnitude V. So V here and V is the same. The flow is steady, atmospheric pressure is Pa everywhere, and question A is find the component of the F, Fx and Fy of the applied vane force and express the force F at the angle
phi between f, right, so fx and fy, there will be a phi, right, so it means that this is the fx and fy, and then horizontal and horizontal in terms of the theta, right, so represent phi in terms of f and theta, that's what it meant, and also here let's ignore the weight of fluid and then main weight within the control volume.
So, like I said, number one is to get the control volume, number two, two and three apply the math equation and also the momentum equation.
So this will be, since we are looking into two states, state one and state two, and this will be our control volume.
Right, so solution, select a control volume cuts through the inlet and exit of the jet through the vane support, and then probably in later chapters, we may consider friction, but here, we don't have to worry about vane friction because it's self-cancelling, so friction here and friction here will be self-cancelling, like I said, step two, so once we define the control volume, then we have to apply the method.
less conservation, right? So here M1 dot and M2 dot should be the same. So we have one inlet and we have one outlet. That should be the same as the M dot. And then let's apply the momentum equation and neglect the weight of the fluid and vane. Then force have to be equated by the MA, right?
So that is the m dot 2 v2 minus m1 dot v1 here is the vector. And then m is the same, so m dot multiplied by d v2 minus v1.
So components of the force in x and y direction will be, so here, so this is the fx, so this is f and this is fx and this is fy, right, this is fx and fy, so fx is, right, so here v2 is what, v2 is v2 cosine theta, v1 will be
V1, sine, theta, right? And then V is the same. So in terms of the magnitude, sorry, V2, sorry, what am I doing? So here, give me one sec, I was, [non-lecture aside omitted]. So here, we have a V here and V1 and V2, right?
So, in x direction, you have v1, v here, and from here, there will be the v cosine theta, right? So m v cosine theta minus m v, right? So there will be m v cosine theta minus 1, and then f y is from the
So this should be m dot. From here, m dot y is happening only in the v2 here, right? So f y is the m dot v2 or v sine theta, where m dot is rho a v, so multiply it by v again, that will be rho a v squared.
Then solution, the resultant force magnitude F is square root of the Fx square plus Fy square, there will be this one, square root of that, square root of that, and add those two.
two, then m dot v, square root of sine, square theta plus cosine theta minus one square, there'll be m dot v, square root of two, one minus cosine theta, there'll be two m dot v,
is the sin theta over 2, right? Then from this geometry, we define that as a phi, then phi is 180 minus tangent, so this is the phi, right? So that will be tangent of x over fy,
phi, so inverse tangent of Fy over Fx, right, that will be 90 plus theta over 2, right, because, so there is 9 over 90 minus theta, and that is the 90 minus theta, so phi will be 90 plus theta divided [Review note: Use the signed components with atan2(Fy,Fx), or 180 degrees minus atan(Fy/abs(Fx)); the final direction is 90 degrees plus theta/2.]
divided by 2, right? Then, so relation between f and theta, so if we rearrange that equation in terms of f and theta, then there is the theta versus f over m dot v, there is a relation.
So m dot and v is the same, but then v can change, right? So if we consider two special cases, theta equals 180, which means that your water is coming in, and then you have a 100% turn, and water is coming out here.
So that's the case, probably there will be the maximum anchoring force will occur. So at theta equal 180, maximum force occurs, the jet is turned around and thrown back in the opposite direction with its moment reversed.
first. Then at very small theta, then we have m dot b theta, 2 theta, right, because 2 sine f theta will be 2, theta over 2 will be theta, right, so f equals m dot b theta, and if phi equals 90,
So if this is a phi, phi is a 90, then there will be a very small zero. The force is linearly proportional to the turning angle theta and acts normal to the jet.
Okay, another example, friction force. I didn't talk too much about the friction force, but whenever there is a solid wall and water is flowing
over the solid, you have to think about the friction. We call it the water resistance, right? So if you think about when you are swimming and swimming soon, you are swimming, but the same situation is you are staying still in the water, but then water is flowing around you, right? Then you will have some friction force on your skin.
So that's the amount of force on the fluid flow. Also, the fluid flow is also experiencing that much of the friction flow, right?
So many engineering applications need to find the friction force exerted by the pipe wall on the fluid flow in a pipe.
So determine the drag force exerted by a flat plate on the flow over it.
So again, you have to have the control volume, right? So this pipe, pipe flow suddenly expands from A1 to A2. So this is A1 and this is A2. So this is 1 and this is open end. So we have some expansion. Assume the flow is steady and incompressible and at wall P1
on the corner annular, annular ring as shown, right? And it is a separation. So later on, I will talk again about the separation and sub-point.
So here, P1, V1, A1 is given here, and also P2 is given, and A2 is given, rho are given, find V2 and the wall friction. So here, what we do is the momentum equation, right? So again, number one step is select the control volume, so that will be our control volume, and then number two, apply the mass conservation
at the inlets and outlets, right? So density is the same. So if we neglect the density, we have the a1, v1 equals a2, v2, and a1, v1, and a2 are given.
So V2 are A1 divided by A2 multiplied by the V1. Then apply the linear momentum equation. Sigma F is M dot, so here M dot V2 minus M dot V1, M2, M2, M1, M1,
here, sorry, this is the, right, there is a typo, so that has to be M1, but M2 dot and M mass flow rate at the station 1 and station 2 should be the same, because mass should not be lost somewhere else, so M dot V2 minus V1, then, and so this is the control volume, and we have to think about the force,
diagram. So we have a P1 acting inward at the state 1, and we have a P2 again acting inward at state 2, and then we have the Pw here, right? And then this is the friction force. So we have Pw in addition to the P1, right?
So what I meant by, in this area, P1, but then this is the Pw, that's what we meant, right? So Fx will be, if we think about the force only in the x direction, and then this one is a positive, and then pressure should be multiplied by the area, so in the one state, the force Fx will be P1, A1,
and then Pw area is A2 minus A1, right? So A2 minus A1 and then right-hand side, P2 is pointing to the left-hand side, so we have to have the negative side, minus P2, A2, A2, and then force, right?
So this is friction force. So friction direction of the friction force is always opposite to the flow direction. So flow is moving this direction. So your direction of the friction is the opposite.
And since we said the right-hand direction, right-hand flowing is a positive, that has to be compensated by the negative sign, right, so minus FF friction force, and that has to be M dot is, if we use, rho is the same, and let's use the A1, B1, A1, B1, and then B2,
minus B1, right? So FF will be, move everything except for the FF, move the FF to the right-hand side, and move the right-hand side into the left-hand side, then we have this relation.
Okay, then, so our golden rule, when we want to calculate a force relation, the number one is the, take the control volume and apply the mass equation,
and apply the momentum equation. But what if our control volume is moving? Don't worry. So we have two velocities. Flow is moving, control volume is also moving. If that's the case, then we will have the relative velocity as if this is fixed, then we follow the same procedure.
So this case is a moving but non-deforming and that translates at constant speed meaning zero acceleration. So the movement of the control volume does not create any force, right? So it's inertial because there is no acceleration.
duration. In this case, the momentum equation is still applicable except that the velocity V should be treated as the relative velocity, right? So example 1 is reconsider the previous example assuming the vane is moving at a constant velocity VB here. Find the component, find the force of the force in terms of the component fx and fy of the component.
applied vane force. So again, number one, select the control volume, cuts through the inlet and exit, and enclosing the water jet and also the vane support. So here relative velocity is, so this is VB, right, then the relative jet velocity VA will be
V_B plus V_A/B. So VR will be V1 minus VB. Why did I take the V1? Because the V1, this is V1 and this is V2, and V1 and V2 are the same in magnitude but then different in the directions, right? So VB is in this direction, so I just took the V1, VR is V1 minus VB.
three. They are in the same direction. Then number two, apply the mass conservation at the inlet and outlet. So m dot m to dot equal m dot where m dot is rho va. So here v should be replaced by the relative velocity. So v1 minus vb. And then let's apply the linear momentum equation. So summation of the all forces should be
is the m dot v2 minus m dot v1, right? And then here, fx is, so first component, so v2, so we have to have x and y component from here as well, so we have the same, m dot vr cosine theta minus 1, fy will be m dot vr sine theta, and vr is v1 minus vb, so we have that relation. [Review note: PDF page 33 has a coefficient error in the expanded expressions: m_dot*Vr = rho*A*Vr^2, not m_dot*A*Vr^2.]
Okay, pretty straightforward. And another example of the moving control volume, I think that is the last example of the momentum equation. So let's stick with me. So example, a water jet of velocity Vj impinges normal to a plate that also moves at the velocity of Vc.
So water jet, but then the impinging plate is also moving. Find the force required to keep the plate moving with zero acceleration, meaning at constant velocity. And density of the jet, water jet, 1000 kg per meter cube, area of jet is 3 cm2, velocity of the water jet,
20 meter per sec, and BC, the velocity of the moving plate, flat plate, that is the 15 meter per sec. Then, again, number one, take the control volume and make sure you include all the inlet and outlet and also the contact surface, right? So there will be your control volume and then you can consider that as an inlet and that as an
outlet, right? And this time, your control volume is also moving at the velocity of Vc, right? Because your control volume is moving along with the flat plate.
So how many states do we have? We have a J state, and you have a state 1 and state 2. So state J is an inlet, and state 1 and state 2 are the outlet, right?
And then since rho is incompressible, rho is a constant, right? So if we have the relative velocity of Ej minus Bc, then you can consider this flat plate is fixed and the water is impinging at the velocity of Ej minus Bc, right?
If that's the case, and even if you don't know the velocity here, the total mass flow rate should be the same, right? So you can have the a1 equal half aj and a2 should be half aj, right? Let's see.
solution, select control volume, cut through the plate support, assumption, steady flow, so no ddt, negligible weight of jet and plate, and assume symmetry, and assume no lateral spreading, it always, you know, moving into the normal direction, see here, okay, by the mass conservation, we have m dot out should be the m dot in, right,
so M.out is here and here so that was the state, where the state was, state 1 is the top, this is state 1, state 1 is state 2 that is out so density should be the same right so rho 1, A1, V1 at the top and then mass flow rate at the bottom outlet, rho 2, A2
V2, that is M dot in. M dot in here is the rho1, rhoj, aj, aj, and V will be Vj minus Vc, okay? Then let's apply the momentum equation. F is momentum flux, right? Sigma, so this one, I will use the sigma summation
because we have more than a single outlet. So M dot out, V out, minus sigma, you have only a single inlet, M in dot, V in, right? And then, we assumed, right, in the here, right, so Vj is a 20 meter per sec,
So V1 equals same as the V2, and then that should be Vj minus Vc, right? Because there is [unclear word; context: constant translational velocity], it is moving at a constant velocity, right? So V1 and V2 should be the same, because it is also symmetric, right? So this one and that one should be the same, and then that should be the same as the V1 and V2, that would be 20 minus 15, right? [Review note: Equal relative inlet and outlet speed also uses the idealized negligible-loss jet model; constant plate velocity alone is insufficient.]
equals 5 meters per second, then fx will be from here, we said v out as zeros, right? So we only have the rx is from the in, right? Because v out is the opposite direction, so minus mj dot vj, [Review note: Zero outlet velocity in the x momentum balance means its x component. The relative outlet speed is 5 m/s, directed vertically.]
So another vj, that should be the relative velocity, so why don't I set that as a uc, uj, uj, it will be minus rho 1, rho j, aj, uj is vj minus vc squared, because you have two of them, one v from the m dot and another v from the u, you have a v squared.
Then Rx is a simple numerical insertion. 1000, rho, 1000, Aj is 0.0003 and Vj is 20, Vc is 15. You have to square it. Then there'll be minus 7.5 Newton.
in the y direction, this direction, and that direction. So from this relation, in the y direction, there's no in component, right? So we only have a component from this term, so we have m1, we have m1 dot v1, and this is small v, small v1,
plus m2 dot small v2. That is, m1 dot v1 plus m2 dot minus v2. So, there will be m1 dot m2 dot the same, right? The mass flow rate, because this is symmetric in the same area,
and then v is the same in the other direction. So ry becomes 0. Okay, guys, that's all for the second recording for the second part of the chapter 3. And in the next video, I'll talk about the Bernoulli equation, conservation of the angular momentum, and conservation of the energy equation. Okay, thank you, guys.